wie ist die lage
dem keine einzige lager ist knüppelhart
natürlich super geil was los in die
wertung und
toll dankeschön
warum
ganz ehrlich wir lieben diese
interviewsituation wir sitzen so gerne
auf dem sofa im schnitt lich ist schön
war
weiß ich jetzt ein bisschen ironisch an
quatsch
ist das erste das war total wegen eines
wirklich echt mal
kurz bitte
den feuchten engen situationen oft alles
knüppelhart deswegen ist supergut das
heißt interview ist für euch nicht eine
lästige begleiterscheinung
das kommt ganz auf das
sind schon gespannt ob du heute zwischen
höchstform aufläuft weil das finden wir
ehrlich gesagt sehr sympathisch immer
was sind denn für euch die
journalistischen höchste
fragen die wir noch nicht so oft gehört
haben und das kommt selten vor dass uns
fragen gestellt werden die wir noch nie
gehört haben
also wie ist die lage war zum beispiel
ist eine frage die haben wir noch nie
vorher gehört
und besser freut uns natürlich wenn ich
nicht zum 5000 zehnmalige sagen müssen
was culcha candela heißt und wie wir uns
gegründet haben
okay das heißt das ist zum beispiel das
ist ich hab das mal boxen nicht erhalten
als erstes mal geschieht lässt seiner
fragen gesagt was wäre denn eine frage
die ihr noch nie so die er mal gerne
gefragt werden würde
hey das ist nicht durch
hey was ist eigentlich mit euch
also für der gerne ich würde gerne mal
gefragt werden
wie jetzt wie jetzt das unserer meinung
nach somit mit integration ist und so
und was wir davon halten komischerweise
krieg die
deutsche nationalmannschaft im fußball
die kriegen bundesverdienstkreuze und
wir sind seit achteinhalb jahren
gelungen das integrationsprojekt was ich
selbst gegründet und finanziert hat
durch sage ich mal auch schwierige
zeiten gegangen ist rein finanziell
völlig ohne spenden
und ich glaube wir sind noch ein kuckuck
uns doch mal an wir sind gute gutes
beispiel für junge leute dass man es
schaffen kann egal wie man aussieht wo
man herkommt und
wie sagen halt so wir sind die neuen
deutschen darüber würde ich zum beispiel
gerne reden aber wie dann meine frage
wie habt ihr das was ist das geheimnis
um miteinander auszukommen also es gibt
ja ganz
ganz einfache dinge kommunikation
im beispiel das habe ich mal erlebt wenn
ein türke
macht meint er ich glaube ja und wenn
deutschland das meint macht meinte er
was ist denn hier los also das ist mal
komisch so genau so genau haben wir das
jetzt nicht erforscht aber bleiben wir
doch bei dem beispiel also wir sind
jetzt klein deutschland wir sind jetzt
als neue deutsche
wir sind alle deutschen wir haben die
deutsche staatsangehörige und das finden
wir halt zum beispiel haben wir uns als
deutsche sehen als
wenn leute sagen ihr seid der multikulti
weil das symbolisiert ein bisschen immer
so eine gesellschaft außerhalb der
gesellschaft und das finden wir dover
wir sind mitten in der gesellschaft und
wenn wir schon dabei sind also fangen
klein an wie wie funktioniert es denn
bei uns dann sagen wir zuallererst die
sprache wir können uns nämlich alle in
einer sprache unterhalten das ist
deutsch also
unsere amtssprache ist deutsch wir
können aber auch alle zb in englisch
reden oder auch wenn es sein muss und
spanisch also das ist schon mal
vorteilhaft
sein muss
und dass da siehst du also dass für die
integration des a und o ist schonmal
erstmal die sprache
und was ist das weitere weil du sagst
das ist das eine was ist das andere
es ist wirklich ganz einfach in zweiter
linie natürlich oder in erster linie gar
nur erster linien bei diesen gesetzen
ist es respekt auf jeden fall den
anderen zuzuhören den anderen der
meinung zu respektieren und das sind
eigentlich zwei und ehrlichkeit
natürlich ehrlichkeit einfach weil das
sind ganz wichtige säulen und und das
ding ist das haben wir auch immer wieder
gesagt hat die leute denken immer dass
es vielleicht bei uns extra prickelnd
ist oder so weil wir irgendwie
verschiedene backgrounds haben so aber
ich glaube jeder in jedem team in jeder
mannschaft in jeder arbeitsgemeinschaft
in jeder firma irgendwie leute
zusammenarbeiten gibt es die gleichen
regeln die befolgt werden muss und genau
so auch bei uns dh ihr habt quasi eine
art kodex
wer gut ist ein ungeschriebenes gesetz
es gibt genau das gibt halt keine
fixierung davon irgendwo in stein
gemeißelt aber wir haben uns von anfang
an als wir uns gegründet haben wir schon
so ein paar sachen überlegt die uns
wirklich wichtig sind die wirklich
sozusagen die grundfesten auch unsere
band sind dazu gehört dass wir in
unseren texten darauf achten was wir
sagen dass wir keine gewalt oder
irgendwie drogen oder sowas propagieren
oder verherrlichen wollen dass wir halt
wirklich respektvoll miteinander umgehen
wollen und so das ist halt so die die
grundlinien den wir oder auf denen wir
aufbauen das gibt's da noch nicht in
buchform oder sie werden irgendwann
vielleicht einmal veröffentlichen aber
das ist ja ein hauptproblem bei dem
miteinander dass man eben respektlos
miteinander umgeht dass der eine würde
sagte gumpel türke und eine andere der
kartoffel oder schweine fressen und dann
ist ja eigentlich atmosphäre schon
vergiftet hatte die rauch sofa also wenn
ihr euch streitet im spiel das dann
überhaupt keine rolle oder ja was macht
denn also das spielt es überhaupt keine
rolle weil wir sind eher menschliche
charakterzüge die irgendwie konflikt
auslösen als irgendwie kulturelle
eigenheiten und so krass und ja die
kulturellen eigenheiten jetzt bei
jugendlichen aus der ganzen welt nun
auch wieder nicht vernehmen sie in
deutschland ist ja besonders seiten im
internet und so weiter mache es gibt ja
auch ein grund warum man hier lebt
nämlich eigentlich entweder irgendwie
also man hat das glück gehabt hier her
zu kommen weil wahrscheinlich das leben
dann besser ist als in dem ursprungsland
von den eltern oder wo man mal
hergekommen ist und
ja es geht das gibt einem messer man
kann man kann irgendwie seine träume und
ziele ja ich hier besser erreichen
deswegen
wer passt man sich auch ein bisschen
auch den gegebenheiten an finde ich ein
weiteres ganz kurz nur zwei kleine
sachen weiteres prinzip für gute
zusammenarbeit und
integration ist für mich auch sinn für
humor
und
wir haben auch kein kodex wir haben nur
canon und sony codec haben wir gar nicht
bei uns
was kodak
und wer wir hatten natürlich auch immer
muss auch also wenn man so viel viele
menschen aus verschiedenen kulturkreisen
ist muss man natürlich auch darauf
achten dass man möglichst gut riecht das
kann totale konflikte auslösen
ich glaube es ist eigentlich relativ
einfach man redet die ganze zeit über
integration und integration ist auch ein
wichtiges thema aber ich denke so wie
wir das hier vor leben hat unser
zusammenleben eigentlich relativ wenig
mit integration zu tun sondern es gibt
so ein schönes deutsches sprichwort wie
es videos in den wald hineinruft so
schallt es auch hinaus ja und ich glaube
am ende ist völlig egal ob das ein
polnisches wäldchen ist oder ob es zu
einem brasilianischen amazonas regenwald
ist das echo ist immer das gleiche am
ende ist wurscht ob mein gegenüber einen
türkis oder ein deutscher oder aus
südamerika kommt es kommt darauf an wie
man miteinander umgeht und es kommt
darauf an dass man sich respektvoll und
tolerant begegnet dem anderen drei das
auch mal zuzuhören auch wenn man
vielleicht eine ganz andere meinung hat
und ich denke das sind die grundfesten
eines positiv orientierten menschlichen
miteinanders ja und da ist dann wirklich
egal wo man herkommt oder wo man hin
will man muss sich einfach ein paar
simple regeln halten und das haben wir
in dieser band von anfang an versucht zu
tun und haben uns das sehr zu herzen
genommen und ich glaube es ist auch ein
schlüssel zu unserem erfolg
und was macht dann ihr in situationen wo
ihr
respektlosen leuten begegnet
naja wir begegnen ja eigentlich nie die
respektlosen leuten oder auf der straße
wäre ich nur gefeiert und vergöttert so
alle seriösen kurzen danke ja
wie gott
nein in der regel ich denke man hat auch
da immer noch die gleichen chancen man
muss einfach diesen leuten positiv
gegenüber treten jahren versuchen
irgendwie klar zu machen dass sie ist
gerade sind die scheiße reden oder dass
dies gerade sind die die eine linie
überschreiten oder
die respektlos begegnen klar ab und
bestimmten punkt macht man das dann auch
nicht mehr irgendwann rechts in eine
neue zeit
dem thema integration heute früher
hatten wir zwei kinder 11 aufeinander
folgende begegnung mit dem älteren
herrschaften der gesellschaft und wir
sind ja nun wirklich auch teilweise
respektierte bürger das von von
deutschland durch meine also irgendwie
so ein bisschen wie haben wir unseren
platz ja auch schon gefunden und ich
also ich finde aber wir sehen nicht so
irgendwie gewalttätig und gefährlich aus
und 2 zwei ältere herrschaften
mit ich würde sagen
ohne migrantenhintergrund oder
migrationshintergrund
haben uns heute doch auch
das fürchten gelehrt am flughafen weil
also aber er wurde zur seite geboxt von
den
four for vorruheständler und und ich
stand im café laden an der kasse und kam
einfach ein typ mit dem aktenkoffer
dahin geschwebt hat einfach vor mir
bestellt aber also alles richtig so und
hat er mich dann nicht gesehen ist das
vielleicht fünf minuten stehe was soll
man da machen
wir keine mit gewalt auf jeden fall
nicht begegnen das ist total bescheuert
die kamen vor irgendwo ist dann
wahrscheinlich total respektierte banker
die auch über die finanzkrise mit
ausgelöst haben die um die 1,5 millionen
abfindung kriegen wir die weltwirtschaft
in den arsch machen oder aber auf jeden
fall ich habe es nicht verstanden also
das sozusagen das ist sozusagen auch ein
schlechtes beispiel für integration für
junge leute wie uns oder noch jüngere
wenn wenn solche menschen so und so wie
gar nicht wahrnehmen oder oder wenn wenn
solche menschen irgendwie so ein wo man
denkt das ist eine gestandene person
dastehen beiden füßen im leben und hat
irgendwie manieren und hat einen
respektablen job wenn der so einfachste
form wie bitte und danke anschuldigungen
stehen sie hier an nicht nicht einhält
da sind schlechtes beispiel
ich will meinen senf dazugeben die
integrationsdebatte ich glaube die
meisten probleme sind gar keine probleme
die wurst und migration geht dann
einfach soziale probleme und da viele
leute ist schwieriger haben in
deutschland mit migrationshintergrund
auch soziale probleme zu bewältigen gibt
es auch oft werden die dann als
sündenbock hergenommen aber ich denke im
endeffekt sind die meisten sachen die
man sozusagen lernen muss hier in
anderen kulturen genauso gang und gäbe
und respekt und toleranz und positiv den
leuten entgegen zu treten das glaube ich
allgemein verbreitet auf der welt und
deswegen ich glaube die debatte ist ein
bisschen ja vielleicht wenn man
eigentlich jemand den schafen peter
zuschieben aber ich glaub das ist nicht
wirklich das problem dass der
verschiedenen kulturen
menschen das heißt wir haben ja
eigentlich gar kein integrationsproblem
sondern wir haben mehr so miteinander
probleme ich glaube ja das ist schon hin
man muss auf jeden fall definieren das
gibt es einmal dass rassismus was mit
wasser herkommt und einmal die
dekoration an sich gesellschaftlich
gesehen weil es gibt es dort deutsche
die müssen auch integriert werden das
waren die gesellschaft und das ist also
dass man alle und und deswegen ist gibt
es halt das problem rassismus und das
andere integration das hat mehr mit
sozialer zu tun mit den umfeld
für mich auch total sowas machen zum
beispiel so ein josef ackermann wenn er
mal nicht arbeitet der muss auch in der
gesellschaft gedreht werden und deswegen
kriegt ja einheit 20 millionen abfindung
ablösesumme hat seinen fußball abfindung
und dann ist ja so heißt aber noch lange
nicht dass er in der gesellschaft wieder
integriert ist dh
das war es am einen ende nicht
integriert ist es am anderen ende auch
nicht integriert dh die die eben
herausstechen und zwar in negativer aber
respektierter art und weise ich sage der
ein oder andere politiker manager banker
wirtschaftslenker der provoziert im
grunde auch dass die leute unten sagen
moment wenn die sich nicht integrieren
warum soll ich mich integriert
definitiven ernsthafte jetzt definitiven
großes zeichen dass diese leute setzen
weil das es geht ja um moral und
verantwortung für die gesellschaft und
das kann man ahnt man jetzt bei der
wirtschaftskrise die herbeigerufen wurde
von einigen wenigen anderen auf jeden
fall kein anzeichen von moral gesehen
keine anzeichen von verantwortung das
ist ein schlechtes beispiel für
jugendliche warum soll jemand der
überhaupt möglichkeiten die bildung und
in den background hat warum sollen der
irgendwo in seiner ecke irgendwie auf
jemand anders achten wenn die leute das
nicht tun
stimmt also ein appell eigentlich an
alle da oben integriert euch mal damit
die integration mal beginnt
auf jeden fall mehr
das ist doch mal kurz über musik reden
seid ihr zufrieden
wir sind gerade sehr zufrieden also mit
musik ist ja nicht ganz so schlecht
jetzt eigentlich stecken oder sind wir
haben ja noch nicht die aktuellen charts
aber weil der trend lässt vermuten dass
es
auch ganz gut sein wird er freut uns
natürlich also ein komplett neues lied
ist was so ein bisschen werbung macht
für unser bestes ende oktober
herauskommt das ist natürlich auch sehr
wichtig dass die leute dazu zugang
finden und das ist natürlich eine gute
voraussetzung wie sie die erste single
abfeiern jetzt müssen sie noch die
verbindung zwischen dieser diesem lied
und dem westhoff herstellen finden und
dort den weg in den laden und dann ist
alles toll aber sonst freut uns die
momentane lage weil es lässt natürlich
da noch entspannter das lässt sich
entspannter arbeiten solchen vorsitz hat
man wenn man solange zusammen ist dann
nicht immer wenn man etwas neues macht
so also gerade noch mal so lange wenn
man ich sag mal wenn man jedes jahr ein
top 10 wird man irgendwann gewöhnt man
sich dran aber er die springt immer so
ein paar jahre und jetzt also hat ihr
hammer waage ziemlich weit vorn monster
war ziemlich weit vorne monster war
letztes jahr
kurz überlegen ja
und jetzt wird auch wieder ganz weit
vorne hat man da trotzdem nicht vor
jeder single und jeder platz thema war
wie so ein bisschen angst wenn man
solange zusammen ist sind wir überhaupt
noch zeitgemäß passen wir rein da kommt
nachher nette frage ganz ehrlich ich
glaube es hat überhaupt nichts damit zu
tun wie lange wir zusammen sind oder wie
wir nicht zusammen und ich denke für
jeden musiker ist es immer wieder total
spannend sachen zu releasen und selbst
wenn du dich dran gewöhnt hat dass du
seit zehn jahren nur noch nummer eins
hits macht dann willst du auch beim
elften mal trotzdem immer noch nummer
eins und niemand kann das garantieren
dass es auch so sein wird also ich
glaube der tag wo du nicht mehr
aufgeregt bist du solltest du den
anderen job so gut okay wobei bei lady
gaga denke ich inzwischen die rechnen
damit dass nummer 1 wird nicht gesondert
auch diese mit sicherheit das gerät
liest ja ich glaube es ist genau das
falsche wort ich habe eigentlich immer
vorfreude da und mal wird die bestätigt
man vielleicht ein bisschen enttäuscht
so aber ich glaube meistens die die
freude überwiegt einfach und zugucken
wenn man den song oder es aber auch die
leute loslässt wie reagieren die
zerreißen sie es oder oder freuen sich
darauf und wir hatten noch nie werden
dass das problem des zerreißen es noch
nie so wirklich laut das problem
vielleicht am anfang dass das ist nicht
genug gab die das überhaupt erreichen
konnten weil ich war so aber das hat
sich auch geändert und alles läuft gut
zu zeigen wobei es gibt ja eine lustige
geschichte von falco als der seinen
nummer 1 hit hat hatte in den usa war
der todtraurig heute sagte das war die
spitze meiner karriere jetzt geht es nur
abwärts
aber wenn es anders wäre immer wieder
nummer eins und dann aber es gut dann
achten wir darauf keine keiner einzigen
usa sonia muss man auch das ist fast
wieder zurück
ich würde mich gerne noch auch bei den
ganzen internet usern bedanken irgendwie
ins porten in einer community egal jetzt
sofort auf welcher natürlich darf ihren
namen denn nun also ja ja so natürlich
also myspace finden wir cool und
facebook und natürlich auch culture de
unsere unserer homebase da stehen immer
die neuesten sache rund und allen hughes
kann die listen und vielen vielen dank
weil wir haben sage ich aber
mittlerweile echten gut aufgestellte
internetpräsenz und danke an euch dass
sie das nutzt und ihr werdet doch
zahlreicher unsere freunde das finden
wir ganz cool wir bemühen uns natürlich
auch da immer wieder frische sachen
aufzuladen und mit euch zu kommunizieren
also keep in touch ein dankeschön